vous qui connaissez quand même bien la
faire est ce que vous avez trouvé le
numéro à charge ou plutôt conforme à ce
qui est la vérité je les trouvais plutôt
conformes je m'attendais même ma à ce
que le documentaire aille plus loin
d'accord parce qu'effectivement en 2018
quand le magazine hebdo sort cette
enquête vous le disais je suis l'une des
porte-parole de nous tout est à ce
moment là je suis je m'intéresse
beaucoup à la politique en général et je
suis très interpellé par la tribune de
marlène schiappa dans le jdd on est
beaucoup revenu sur cette tribu
invités incité par le gouvernement a
donné une fin écrit dans une tribune
dans le jdd dans lequel elle évoque un
homme charmant dont les éléments de
langage quand même très connoté qui vont
dans le sens de la défense de nicolas
hulot et à ce moment là moi je vois là
je réagis avec mes tripes avec ce à quoi
je crois c'est que at elle pu y aller à
jacques audet
à l'écart mais quand elle part c'est ça
y est ça tu es tu prêt à galway et et je
reçois un message reprise est sur
twitter d'une personne qui me remercient
et qui me dit je vous remercie d'autant
plus que je suis une des victimes de
nicolas hulot et et après c'est toujours
pareil on sait pas qui nous écrit sur
twitter
et elle commence à me raconter des
choses à me donner beaucoup de détails
moi j'ai quand même la culture des
vérifications de l'info et je trouve que
ce qu'elle me dit ah ça se recoupent
plutôt bien et cette personne s'était
cydia que vous avez donc découvert hier
dans l'émission envoyé spécial victor
justement regardez mon valois c'est une
belle tradition à faire l'émission
semble maintenant haïtien de ces
d'extraits s'il vient raconte avec
émotion d'ailleurs c'était très dur ce
témoignage de deux 2 cl comment l'ancien
ministre essayait de lui imposer une
fellation après l'avoir emmené de force
sur un parking et silvia elle vous avez
contactés sur les réseaux sociaux ou
regarder il s'arrête donc après sur un
parking et la voilà il sort son sexe
ça va assez vite il
il a défait son pantalon
il a sorti son sexe il a pris ma main
et m'a demandé si je l'avais déjà fait
avec des garçons si j'avais l'habitude
de genre
de caresses voilà je me rappelle que
pour que ça s'arrête je lui en bas je
lui embrasse
bas du bourg
parce que je sais que je suis coincé en
fait
ça s'est un moment travailler en plus
pour sylvia l'escale dit sylviane ont
voté moi je dit les faits sont
invérifiables car ils se sont déroulés
il ya plus de trente ans ils sont
prescrits par la loi et on voit là les
ailes extrêmement touchée
c'est vrai que ça cesse et c'est
incroyable quand elle nous raconte son
odyssée c'est fou qu'on puisse faire ça
ici lui raconte ensuite ce qui se passe
après l'agression sexuelle est ce que
nicolas hulot lui aurait dit regarde et
la voilà il a rien dit il a redémarré on
est reparti il m'a redépose et au
trocadéro il m'a dit une phrase qui va
me hanter pendant des années oui il m'a
dit remaquiller vous un peu parce qu'on
va vous avez fait des trucs par contre
je fais un choix tout de suite de
deux le masque est en tout cas parce que
forcément il ya du monde au bout du
chemin qui va me dire alors c'était
comment nicolas hulot voilà c'est à dire
que l'âge commence déjà à me construire
cette carapace
vous avons entendu le témoignage de deux
civières et elle vous a contacté cécilia
ce que vous nous disiez il ya un instant
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous avez vous
avez vous êtes en relation avec elle
encore non est là elle a supprimé le
fameux compte twitter est là elle avait
d'ailleurs à ce moment la fédé des
tweets d'accord il ya un moment où elle
a essayé de parler puis à la elle a pris
part à nouveau elle a supprimé les
tweets moi j'ai énormément penser j'ai
énormément penser à elle sait ces trois
dernières années
et je fais partie de celles qui sur les
réseaux sociaux initialement puis en
mobilisant des copines notamment chez
chuo élevé on a vraiment veiller weill
éveillé pour elle mais aussi pour les
autres à ce qu' il ne sois pas invitée
par ce parti autant qu'il pouvait europe
écologie
que vous ont dit des les victimes après
la diffusion en avait eu mais maintenant
j'en ai j'en ai pas j'ai envoyé plein
avec l'une des victimes que vous
connaissez ou envoyé une lettre à
brigitte macro est tout à fait alors que
nicolas hulot est encore ministre de
l'écologie ouais une des victimes qui
témoignait hier a effectivement en 2018
envoyé une lettre à brigitte macron de
ce que je sais une deuxième lettre a été
envoyée à brigitte maquereau au même
moment ça c'est un journaliste politique
qui n'a rapporté et il s'est fait
confirmer l'information par l'elysée
donc à notre connaissance au moins deux
lettre aurait été envoyée à brigitte
maquereau en 2018 ce qui ressort c'est
qu'un ça a provoqué un rom ou et que
enfin un remous mais malgré tout le
président macron à
a affirmé son soutien à
nicolas hulot a dit que ces révélations
le laisser froids comme bernard oui
alors vous avez raison sauf que madame
macron ben j'en ai parlé avec elle elle
reçoit plus de venir vous en ayez par
lesquels très bien oui c'est ce que je
veux dire et je suis pas du tout de
modiques mais je connais un peu madame
macron et je vous jure qu'elle est
extrêmement sensible à chaque fois qu'on
écrit une lettre que l'un des messages
elle essayait de faire bouger sauf
qu'elle reçoit je crois pas à peu près 3
400 m c'est la première dame qui reçoit
le plus de lettres depuis première dame
et ça franchement elle savait pas
l'était pas au courant vous savez quel
un cabinet qui gère ça on ne lui a pas
dit je peux vous le dire parce qu'elle
me l'a dit et ça fabrice et on n'a pas
pris cette lettre au sérieux non c'est
pas ça c'est que vous savez il ya
tellement non non elle n'a pas été très
long lui a pas dit en tout cas d'accord
c'est pas mal oui donc à
l'elysée absolument par d'autres
personnes de l'elysée qui elle aurait dû
remonter la france à cannes n'a pas eu
bien sûr puisque je lui ai posé la
question il ya deux jours pour tout vous
dire donc voilà est en revanche pour
vous parler du président dé ce qu'on
avait dit à l'époque vous savez
effectivement que le président avait dit
qu'il le soutenait un faire quelque part
ainsi que d'autres ministres à ce moment
là on a été tout à fait au début de la
faire c'était juste rappelez vous
c'était pour la jeune fille qui ne
voulait pas qu'on dise et qui ne voulait
pas porter plainte en plus et qu'ils ne
voulaient pas qu'on parle d'elle on
était vraiment au début la faire je ne
veux pas disculpé qu'il se soit vous
pensez bien est ce qu'on a vu hier est
épouvantable et on embrasse les
plaignantes et on sait pas quoi faire
mais vous voyez ce qu'il ya dans ce
genre d'affaires et là je profite qu'à
nice soit là parce que qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé là moi je suis sûr et
certain de savoir ce qui s'est passé sur
cette affaire
quelqu'un reçoit une lettre ça ne s'est
pas brigitte mâcon qui valent à dire
personne
n'y voit la lettre il dit oulala ça ça
c'est des emmerdes je vais pas en parler
je vais le mettre de côté
c'est ça comme ça que ça se passe ce
bernard je sais pas c'est possible je
sais pas vers sa démesure de chaque jour
elle est comme ça c'est grave moi je
reçois une la limite ça c'est grave je
le dis la lettre a été remonté d'accord
ok bon en tout cas mes rayons on le voit
très bien dans leurs portes à cannes
connu début quand il a avec chirac il
est très ami de chirac dont on pense
qu'il est protégé axa avec sarkozy on
voit avec ségolène royal on le voit avec
hollande on le voit kron donc
effectivement il ya un côté un peu vache
je connais les puissants donc malgré
tout je passe entre les gouttes et les
affaires ne remonte pas effectivement
tous les présidents avant notamment
jacques chirac était collée à nicolas
hulot est peut-être déjà était-il au
courant de certaines choses on sait pas
et tant d'autres derrière tous les
résidents derrière alors dans le
témoignage à cinq victimes est-ce que
vous avez connaissance d'autres victimes
oui présumé bien alors avec donc enjoint
c'est l'une des deux journalistes de
l'ancien hebdomadaire abdou donc
journaliste d'investigation la base
c'est vraiment pas un idéologue c'est
vraiment pas une féministe elle est à
l'origine de la révélation du scandale
du médiator fait pas une féministe à la
base elle est en fait contacté par un
policier elle est laurent valdiguié
c'est un policier qui leur dit en fait
je pense qu'il va être temps de creuser
sur nicolas hulot est donc avec un
logement mais aussi vanessa vanessa
jérôme qui est une chercheuse absolument
génial spécialiste des violences
sexuelles en politique qui a d'ailleurs
était à l'origine avant même médiapart
de la révélation de la sphère beaupain
d'accord avec et vanessa on a remonté à
l'époque c'est ce témoignage et moi j'ai
eu vent d'un autre témoignage il ya
quelques semaines un vieux témoignage
donc s'offrit 17 hres sem ouais et je
suis convaincu qu'il y en a d'autres
souverains alors viens nous avions été
présente sur l'un des tournages de
nicolas hulot en tant que militante
écologiste spécialiste des abysses elle
racontait deux parties au costa rica
avec une certaine appréhension il
raconte aussi une anecdote qui sait des
années plus tard regarde leur entourage
avant de partir en tournage me dit
éviter situation où tu es seul avec lui
donc si vous travaillez c'est au
restaurant de l'hôtel c'est pas dans ta
chambre et n'ouvre pas
si frappe à ta porte le soir etc enfin
j'en fais semblant de dormir dans des
consignes comme ça 2-3 jeudi mail un
problème là quand même selon claire
nouvian nicolas hulot n'a eu aucun geste
déplacé pendant le tournage mais elle
affirme que quelques années plus tard
après une réunion de travail il aurait
tué un comportement déroutant ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu'on a deux jeunes
ensemble on est allés chez lui prendre
un café et au moment de me raccompagner
voilà il a quand même essayé de
m'embrasser et la fim et nicolas n'est
sérieux enfin qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc ça c'est rien à faire là il y a
clairement un dysfonctionnement dans ses
rapports aux femmes tout le monde de
court en deçà et au tour de quad du fait
qu' il ya beaucoup de consommation
beaucoup de consommation qui a beaucoup
de jeunes filles qui passent à la
casserole
pardon on est en train de tout mélanger
la lady et il a essayé d'embrasser il
sort avec beaucoup de femmes et alors on
va mélanger ça avec des agressions
sexuelles et moi je suis désolé alors
j'ai été très touché par les témoignages
évidemment mail enquête je suis désolée
elle est complètement à charge mais un
truc qui m'a choqué dès le début de
l'émission elise lucet elle reçoit la
réalisatrice elle dit alors pourquoi
vous avez voulu enquêter sur nicolas
hulot et 10 passes et 13 ans en 2017
unit aux états unis il y avait un
rigorisme stein et puis non sediba est
ce qu'on pourrait faire un mythe ou
français on s'est dit bah tiens ya une
plainte contre nicolas hulot donc on va
enquêter sur lui mais journalistique
mans c'est dégueulasse de faire ça mon
pain d'aussi à charge en six ans bah
tiens on va se faire un mythe ou à la
française on va aller chercher nicolas
hulot fait pas fait c'est exactement ce
qu'il faisait au début d'émission
vraiment ce qui fait pas c'est ce qu'ils
ont près tout cas c'est ce qu'elle
explose ça dégueulasse mais là sur sa
anaïs points / 7 / sur ce témoignage
elle est très sympa ni ses hôtels en
parler aujourd'hui mais c'est en rigole
limite à dire et c'est bon il veut
tenter que tout le monde quoi ces essais
mais là elle parle pas de d'agression
oui mais maintenant c'est fait pour ça
dit elle dit on sait qu'il est elle
avait de nombreuses conquêtes mais ça
c'est ouais alors tu as fait don juan
est d'ailleurs brise toussaint parlé à
nicolas tu as nicolas hulot sa
réputation de bon jugement encore
heureux être un donjon être un dragueur
un séducteur c'est encore permis ce qui
est illégal c'est l'agression sexuelle
est un jour je rejoins mes ya un mélange
des genres qui est gênant franchement on
peut pas avec le même ton la même
musique la même réalisation dire d'un
côté j'ai subi d'agression sexuelle ce
qui est extrêmement grave et j'avais
jamais le ton de claire parce que cléry
elle elle dit voilà ben ali
il n'a rien tenté avec moi là bas mais
mode quelques mois plus tard il essaie
quand même de m'embrasser cesser ces
mythes et voilà ils voter ils vont
tenter toujours un truc c'est pas clair
le problème c'est le reportage qui
compile ces témoignages et qui met ça à
côté d'une agression sexuelle elle dit
d'abord bas on s'est vus il a rien fait
au kebab de quoi tu dis ça et après elle
dit il a juste essayé de m'embrasser
d'accord mais un homme qui essaie de la
race est une femme ça existe à la
complexité justement alors il ya un
autre témoin d'afrique est très fort et
là là c'est une autre histoire c'est
cécile qu'a subi un véritable
traumatisme
après une tentative de viol présumée de
nicolas hulot il ya plus de 20 ans et ce
qu'elle nous raconte l avaleur 23 ans et
travailler pour l'ambassade de france à
moscou regarde bien sûr ils commencent à
me parler comment qu'est ce que tu fais
c'est là qu'il devient entreprenant dit
si tu veux
je peux t'aider
avoir un boulot à tf1 est là et peu sa
main sur ma cuisse
et et messieurs je peux t'aider à voir
un bout et f6
non merci je des
décades la main et il insiste et
après c'est plus la main sur la cuisse
et se jette sur moi et ses membres à ces
émeutes ou se laissant entre jambes je
le repousse et j'ai frappé au visage bon
je crois que le nom était très clair je
crois que le nom une fois le nom deux
fois plus je crois que je crois que j'ai
clairement exprimé que je ne souhaitais
pas avoir une relation sexuelle avec ce
monsieur mais c'est pour ça que suis pas
du tout d'accord avec guillaume parce
que justement c'est bien parce qu'on
voit la complexité c'est pas une
compilation c'est à dire qu'il ya des
femmes qui n'ont pas les mêmes défense
les unes des autres et que lui en tant
que soit gresser soit séducteur soit
prédateurs soient violeur il n'a pas à
se comporter de la même manière suivant
les victimes donc moi je trouve que
c'est juste est justement très important
parce que ça libère la parole des femmes
et justement on n'est pas du tout tout
sur le même plan oui mais la portée
médiatique de ça c'est que les gens
voient une accumulation de témoignages
et se disent voilà il ya tant de femmes
qui se sont fait de violer ses les
raccourcis qui sont faits dans la tête
des gens et c'est plus complexe que ce
n'est le tribunal médiatique s'est mis
qu'il veut quand il appelle bourdin en
disant recevez moi je vais en parler
c'est ce qui est une enquête sur lui
c'est normal assez mais qui le déclenche
on a là elise lucet qui a essayé
d'appeler nicolas hulot hier regarde sa
création sont lourdes 1 ce sont des
accusations d'agressions sexuelles et de
viol donc
vous imaginez bien dans ce cadre là on
ne peut pas ne pas vous demandez vous
quel est votre version des faits
[Musique]
pardonnez moi mais ça vous surprend que
je ne vais pas me retrancher année on
pige à dire je n'ai jamais eu de
relation
j'ai dit que
ça m'intéressait pas une question de
reconnaître
donc la cci l'année entière nicolas
hulot oui mais c'est insupportable on au
commissariat la commissaire lucienne et
france on peut il pleut il pleut il peut
réagir et encore une fois je ne juge pas
du tout des accusations sont avérées
évidemment c'était très grave voilà
qu'il ait mis la donne elles sont
dégueulasses il ya prescription comment
on fait si y'a pas le tribunal met
d'accord mais un des meilleurs sans
parler l'ancien maire s'il est innocent
et bien comme tu dis le veut le tribunal
médiatique voilà ce type à l'antenne en
2d a dit le quai des
témoignages font que c'est dégueulasse
mais s'il n'est pas
là on dirait qu'on laisse finalement
mais là on a un interrogatoire sur des
accusations 20 des violences présumées
devant 4 millions de personnes voilà les
quatre noms de personnes qui voient ça
elle est clairement
à charge elle sert quels le jugeront
posant ces questions n'est pas neutre
voilà moi ça me gêne ces méthodes là
elle me gêne je pense qu'à des manières
effectivement c'est bien d'en parler ça
quand tu vas sur bruce toussaint ou
devant bourdin pour s'expliquer il se
défend moi j'aime à cet endroit n'était
pas encore passé des faits parce qu'il
savait que l'anc est allé sortir il
savait quel mensonge mais comment il
sait il le suit entendu les témoignages
que vous avez vu les journalistes ça
fait des années qu'ils aident les
connaissances et compte et de les faire
paraître dans différents médias que il
ya des tas de médias qui ont déjà eu ces
témoignages entre les mains et que les
médias les différents médias
systématiquement étaient appelés voir
nicolas hulot et par l'avocate monde et
que des médias commencé à enquêter il y
avait tout un système qui se mettait en
place et effectivement malheureusement
on arrive à ça mais s'intéresse à un
nouveau témoignage qui est sorti
c'est maureen dor rapidement une d'or
c'était un ami d'enfance de oui oui
vraiment grâce aux reportages donc
d'autres témoignages font tourner et
quand elle a appris qu envoyé spécial
traiter du sujet des agressions
présumées nicolas hulot l'animatrice
belge humo rinne a fait parvenir une
lettre à l'émission qui a été publié
hier soir dans cette lettre elle affirme
avoir été harcelée par nicolas il ne lui
aurait sauté dessus alors qu'elle était
âgée de 18 ans tout commence quand elle
envoie une lettre à nicolas hulot parce
qu'elle a adoré son livre il lui répond
que de passage en belgique qui serait
ravi de la rencontrer la rencontre se
déroule dans le bar d'un hôtel avant que
nicolas hulot se montrent plus
entreprenants au bout d'un quart d'heure
il me dit des journalistes doivent venir
l'interviewer il ment pau propose de
l'accompagner dans sa chambre pour les
attendre je la compagne donc aussitôt
dans sa chambre le voilà qui me saute
dessus et tente de m'embrasser je le
repousse étonné effrayé en lui faisant
cette réponse si naïve mais vous avez
une femme et lui de me répondre mais
cela n'a rien à voir et que je serai une
parenthèse
donc la savoie la cccc un témoignage qui
est arrivé hier de deux de maureen
qu'est ce qui se passe mathieu non je
reconnais que ça commence à faire
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup voilà ce que
j'allais dire les différences entre les
missions sur dsk par exemple connaît
mieux il n'y a pas très longtemps et
surcoûts bernanke est ici c'est que dsk
il y avait des frais des faits avec des
montages financiers des choses voilà
tangible la serbe ex est une émission
qui n'est faite que de témoignages donc
malgré tout on pourrait dire quand même
c'est de l'humain contre de l'humain
racontera pas voilà parole contre parole
sans sac c'est un petit peu gênant dans
la manière est effectivement de
catherine téléspectateurs alors qu'il
n'est pas encore jugé après oui bien sûr
mon consentement perdre hamon mon
ressenti profond mais tout le monde s'en
fout c'est qu'effectivement oui à ne
plus ça commence à faire beaucoup et le
problème du tribunal médiatique c'est la
prescription en fait c'est parce qu'on
veut pas les entendre et ci avait pas de
prescription peut-être qu'il y aurait
moins tribunal médiatique ou alors très
bien merci d'avoir réagi là-dessus anaïs
et un dernier beau bonsoir
s'envoyer des cas
oui enfin je rejoins tout à fait ça mais
encore une fois on y avait aussi cette
affaire pose aussi la question de la
complicité politique et ça me semble
vraiment intéressés intéressant et
important d'y revenir je crois que
certaines personnes de votre équipe en
ut pauline la voix au téléphone il avait
quitté une militante europe ecologie les
verts qui a été écarté de la campagne de
nicolas hulot en 2012 par les équipes
les proches de nicolas hulot à ma
connaissance ce sont certaines personnes
qui sont passées chez en marche depuis
et des personnes qui l'ont écarté parce
qu'ils avaient en lui disant mais tu
excite trop le candidat ça devient
dangereux donc moi ce qui m'interpelle
mais encore une fois en tant que
citoyenne je pense quand je pense qu'en
tant que citoyens et citoyennes on doit
se demander ce qu'on attend des
personnes qui sont censés nous
représenter qu'est-ce qu'ils font que
ces personnes sont dignes de nous et de
leur pouvoir ou pas et en l'occurrence
il ya beaucoup trop de gens qui savaient
des choses et qui savent à qui ont
contribué continuer à le mettre en avant